saudi arabia intercepts rockets over
riyadh on saturday night
you have to go oh my god saudi state
media said they came from yemen
fired by houthi rebels several
explosive-laden drones
targeted other southern saudi cities
the attack came as houthi rebels pushed
forward in the northern yemeni province
of marib
they launched an offensive against the
saudi-backed yemeni government
here in early february saturday was the
most violent day yet
the mahrib front is one of the hottest
war fronts
since the beginning of the aggression on
yemen this has been the situation since
the beginning and except for a small
period
after more than six years of war the
houthis want marib because it's the
yemeni government's last
northern bastian to capture it could
bolster the houthis at the negotiating
table this is a very critical battle
that's taking place
it looks like both sides would like to
be
in a stronger bargaining position in
anticipated
peace talks the problem of course is
that
these short-term gains they are thinking
of
could actually derail the new peace
process
launched by the new u.s administration
the yemeni government has issued urgent
calls for the houthis to stop their
offensive
they warn of a humanitarian catastrophe
marab is already home to the largest
concentration of displaced yemenis
an estimated two million people
still the government is fighting back on
saturday they reported killing
350 houthi fighters in just 30
hours and called rebel efforts a suicide
mission
when the yemeni government urges an end
to the fighting it's not a sign of
weakness we make these calls out of
responsibility
but regarding the fighting the attacking
forces were few in numbers and they were
defeated
but revenge is hard to swallow when
you're starving
for two-thirds of the population some 20
million people
food is what they need the un estimates
400
000 children under 5 are severely
malnourished
and that they are in their last weeks
and months
both sides say the other is putting
civilians at risk
and yet neither stop shelling charlotte
al jazeera